this video is brought to you by
manscaped.com the premium Global brand
for Men's Grooming and hygiene products
if you're someone like me who values
quality and convenience in their
bathroom products then look no further
than manscaped manscape sent me their
performance package 4.0 which is an
all-in-one Men's Grooming kit for body
hair removal from head to toe so let's
check it out behold the lawnmower 4.0
trimmer this is an amazing waterproof
cordless trimmer that can be used on
hair anywhere on your body that's right
fellas this is one device that can be
used for all your hair up here and
deionanda and I have to say this trimmer
being waterproof and cordless really
comes in the clutch because I can do
stuff like this in the shower and not
worry about any messy cleanup it also
has ceramic blades with skin safe
technology which really helps reduce all
those Nicks and cuts and that's not all
for a limited amount of time when you
purchase the performance package 4.0 kit
you get two free gifts
the shed travel bag and the manscaped
anti-chafing boxer briefs the boxers are
super comfortable and feels like I'm
sitting on clouds right now so what are
you waiting for head on over to
manscapes.com to get 20 off plus those
two free gifts when you use the code
Bandit at checkout and now on to the
video
if I had a penny for every scary or
disturbing item or place or enemy in a
from soft game I'd have like a million
pennies which would be like ten thousand
dollars so you know that that'd be nice
but the point is from demon souls to
Dark Souls to bloodborne to sakuro the
creep factor is strong and it's
especially true of fromsoft's latest
Smash Hit Adventure game Elden ring
since this is in fact the spookiest of
all months and since it's been a hot
minute since we covered Elden ring on
the channel and since I love it so much
I figured we'd have ourselves a good
old-fashioned top 10 creepiest spookiest
most disturbing and downright scary
discoveries in Elden ring list some of
which are commonly found and others of
which you may not heard of here we go
number 10 grafted Scions and their
various body parts this was discovered
by Zully The Witch on YouTube and while
it's a popular discovery that lots of
fans probably already know about it's so
disturbing that I just had to put it on
this list simply put the grafted Scions
appear to have many many limbs attached
some of which are not even human all to
a giant troll looking torso complete
with a child's face as its main face
Elden ring took the concept of body
horror and grafting to a new level and
the king of it all is godric the grafted
himself and even though he's also
extremely disturbing there's just
something about a child being included
in the grafted Scions body that makes my
stomach turn number nine land octopuses
I know what you're thinking yeah they're
gross and tentacally but things being
gross and technically is pretty much the
norm with friendsoft games so what's so
spooky about these things well if you
happen upon a land octopus ovary which
will be dropped 100 of the time upon
defeating an adult and if you happen to
read the description of it you'll know
why it's so creepy because it reveals
that land octopuses actually reproduce
by ingesting human blood think of it
like a giant technical-laden mosquito
that pops out babies the more blood it
sucks up yeah kill it with fire number
eight sir Gideon of nears Revelation now
this one is a bit more abstract than
visual but at least to me it's still
plenty creepy so you know how Gideon is
overall a pretty chill dude how helps
you out with important information about
areas and people in the lands between
eventually though as most fans know he
tries to kill you now he's not
particularly a hard boss to kill and
sure the whole friend turned anything is
kind of depressing looking at you live
but what makes this creepy is Gideon's
reasons for attacking you which you do
have to delve through some lore to find
out see the last time you saw him he was
in the round table hold as it began to
burn alongside the err tree he mentions
that he'll get out of there soon to
avoid you know burning to death but
first he's going to gain as much
knowledge as possible before departing
and then when you next approach him he's
standing in between you and the Elden
throne and says that None Shall take the
throne he says that America has high
hopes for us that we continue to
struggle for eternity and as he dies he
says that he knows in his bones that a
tarnished cannot become Eldon Lord a man
cannot kill a God and if you read the
description of his armor it says that
when he glimpsed into the will of Queen
America he shuddered in fear at the end
which should not be it's abstract it
could be explained with theories but the
point here is that Gideon who was
recently such a help along your path of
becoming Eldon Lord suddenly discovered
something unknown that made him truly
believe that no tarnished should even
approach the throne something that
America was planning that was so dark
and so frightening that he would rather
go so far as to try to kill you to
prevent it from happening and that is
just chilling number seven going right
back to visual scares would be the
dancing celebrants of daminulla the
Windmill Village I mean I don't think
there's a universe where a bunch of old
women drenched in blood laughing and
dancing around in circles isn't creepy
but what's more is that these women use
weapons made of human bones that plus
the fact that a nearby Spirit recans his
dying words as eek I hear a festive
Melody no no don't skin me my hide is
filthy I swear and the fact that they
have a thing for biting their own blood
and spewing it out at you means that
these dancing ladies are probably
cannibals who skin their victims eat
their flesh and use the their bones as
various tools all the while dancing
around and laughing again theories could
prove connections between them and the
godskin apostles for instance since one
is located on top of the village but for
all intents and purposes every single
thing there is to discover about the
celebrants of the Windmill Village is
absolutely bone chillingly horrifying
moving on number six shabiri grapes let
me tell you a story once upon a time
there was a lady named hayata hayata is
blind hayata seeks to become a finger
Maiden hayata constantly asks you for
some grapes which give her a vision of a
distant light whenever she eats them and
she wishes to follow this light claiming
that when she arrives at it she will
then become a Bonafide finger Maiden
well if you read the description for
what a shibiri grape is you'll find that
it's not a grape at all it's an eyeball
a human eyeball that she calls sweet
it's just I don't even want to talk
about it anymore number five reichard's
rebirth most people know that reichardt
was kind of a weird dude he bonded with
the god devouring serpent becoming huge
and super nasty by letting the serpent
eat him most people have no problem
killing him but not many people returned
to his body afterwards and if you do
what you'll find is most horrifying
tanith his baby mama is pretty broken up
about her Lord's death so broken up that
she wants to bring him back you know
like what happened when he was eaten by
the god devouring Serpent and came back
as the serpent so she starts eating him
if you try to talk to her she literally
tells you to give her some time because
she's got a lot to eat through talking
aimlessly to reichardt and asking him to
become alive within her so that they can
one day Devour the gods together you
know what they say love knows no
boundaries number four selvius's doll
basement one of the members of Ronnie's
crew is a man named perceptor Selby's
and he's a jerk and nobody likes him but
to make matters worse if you go to this
ruined building in between Rena's rise
and Ronnie's rise you'll find that it
has a hidden basement which can be
uncovered by hitting a false wall and
boy oh boy does it hold Joy inside it's
salvius's secret private basement where
he keeps his puppets as he calls them
which are motionless bodies of once
living characters what's worse is that
their eyes seem to follow you around
implying that they may still even be
alive sylvius also tries to have you
make nepheli Lou into his personal
puppet as well as Ronnie herself and if
you do his questline I'm not sure I
could ever forgive you number three the
death Birds now the discoveries in lore
surrounding these birds isn't anything
particularly scary in fact they're
actually extremely interesting because
they're apparently Children of the twin
bird which is an extremely cell
dimensioned Envoy of an outer God they
were also the Bringers of death in the
age quote before the herd tree so you
can actually learn a lot about the world
of the lands between by reading their
lore but what's scary about them is
their freaking appearance seriously this
face will give you nightmares to make
matters even worse they're all field
bosses meaning they don't have any one
particular location just an area that
they wander around so really when you
encounter them you didn't go find them
they found you so you'll just be walking
around adventuring and all of a sudden a
literal deaf bird that looks like this
will descend upon you and deliver you
death most swiftly yeesh number two the
singing bat women I know that everyone
knows about this one but darn it it
still creeps me the heck out not only
are these bat ladies old and fleshy and
naked which is just Eerie and unsettling
in general but the lyrics to their song
also seems to imply that they were
cursed into this form by a quote golden
one and that previously they were
destined for motherhood their appearance
plus the fact that they do actually want
to kill you plus their choice of
normally desolate environment plus their
Latin chant song is a discovery that
though common was so impactful to so
many Elden ring players that it just had
to be on my list and the first few times
that I encountered them it's seriously
messed with me before we get to number
one let's just bring attention to a few
honorable mentions why don't we finger
creepers giant multi-fingered spider
hands huge nope energy astel the natural
born and it's twin their design alone
night mere fuel it's like a human skull
with mandibles not to mention they're
extremely frustrating boss fights which
are probably also considered nightmare
fuel just on account of how hard they
are but okay that's enough stalling on
to the final scary Discovery number one
mikola and the mowgwin dynasty I know
that most fans know about moog's
disturbing obsession with mikola and how
he like dilutes himself into blood and
enters mikola's body but the more you
look into everything that's happened
between these two and moog's true
intentions the more disturbing and
terrifying it gets for instance did you
know that Mo tried to force himself upon
mikola his own half-brother with the
appearance and body of a small child if
you read the description of moog's
remembrance it states that quote no
matter how much of his bloody bed
chamber he tried to share he received no
response from The Young emperion I don't
know if this means that mikola was able
to resist anything happening or if this
means that Moog did things over and over
and Nicola never did anything in
response I'm not sure but if this this
doesn't scream some Unholy combination
of incestuous pedophilia to you I don't
know what does and personally that's
horrifying who knows what all he did to
mikola to make him in this state
whatever the state may be not knowing if
he's alive or dead huddled up in an
egg-like cocoon in a mutated body with
Moog literally coursing through his
veins and that is the most disturbing
part of Eldon ring to me but that's just
my list what did you think did this
video reveal any new scary secrets in
the game or did you already know about
all this stuff also is there something
even creepier that I missed let me know
in the comments below also thank you so
much for watching please consider
leaving a like if you enjoyed the video
and want to see more Eldon ring on the
channel and subscribe if you haven't
already for more gaming lore super
Thanks goes to all the members of my
Bandit crew of which I have another name
to announce say hello to PL Comics who
just joined up right here on YouTube If
you watching would like to have a part
in keeping the channel going and maybe
even getting a nice little badge beside
your name then feel free to press that
join button below or follow the links in
the description there are many ways to
contribute to the cause but that's about
all I've got for this one so be sure to
follow me on my socials and I'll see you
next time this is Bandit signing out
[Music]